Bueno, pues después de haber estado trabajando
con los videos de porqué hacemos las mismas
cosas de ambos lados, y después de haber
estado trabajando con la idea de la balanza,
en este video lo que vamos a hacer son
algunos ejemplos.
Entonces vamos a empezar por éste que dice, "x"...
voy a cambiar de color porque éste como que
no me gusto...
a ver, vamos a cambiar de color...
ok, ya tengo un color...
Entonces éste dice, "x" más 7 es igual a 10.
Entonces otra vez, lo que voy a hacer es restar
7 de ambos lados  y entonces
de este lado resto 7, de este lado resto 7.
Y entonces como estamos haciendo lo mismo
de ambos lados, ahora vamos a resolver,
"x" más 7 menos 7, pues resulta que esto
se cancela y solo me queda "x" y de este lado,
10 menos 7, me queda 3.
Como hemos estado haciendo lo mismo de ambos
lados, entonces "x" es igual a 3.
Vamos con otro ejercicio.
Éste otro dice algo así, como "a" menos
5 es igual a -2.
Bueno, lo que tiene de interesante este ejercicio,
es que tiene números negativos en ambos lados,
pero vamos a proceder de una manera muy semejante.
Entonces lo que vamos a hacer es sumar
5 en ambos lados...
y aquí sumo 5.
Y ahora, vamos a resolver, entonces de este
lado, "a" más 5 menos 5,
pues se cancelan estos dos y solo me queda "a" y de este lado -2 más 5 es igual a 3
y entonces otra vez como hicimos lo mismo de ambos lados, entonces "a" es igual a 3.
Nos vemos en el próximo video.